merci ça râle irene nous avoir rejoints
vous êtes porte parole du modem ancien
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse
candidate en loire atlantique vous
arrivez avec 37 points 45% des voix on
va vous poser la même question que tout
à l'heure un alignement chaleur pourquoi
le parti du président et il en
difficulté alors que bain à chaque fois
à chaque élections législatives qui
suivent une élection présidentielle
normalement ils surperforment
aujourd'hui le moment de vérité va être
dimanche prochain ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il y à une forte abstention
cette forte abstention elle se sent
d'ailleurs plus particulièrement d'un
autre camp dans che le camp des modérés
des sociaux démocrates qui ne voulait
pas porter leur voix vers un candidat de
la new baisse de cette alliance
absolument fait de bric et de broc sans
valeurs communes et pour autant qu'ils
n'avaient pas envie non plus de porter
une voie vers nos candidats au premier
tour donc pas de mer donc un petit mea
culpa qu'est ce qui s'est passé je crois
que finalement gagnoa issia je veux
adresser les électeurs moi ce que je
comprends c'est que après plusieurs
crises qui se sont enchaînés il y a un
goût 2 est ce que la politique ça change
vraiment les choses et j'avais envie de
rappeler c'est ce que je rappelle le
matin midi et soir sur sur le terrain
que oui la politique change des choses
et que on ne joue pas à la revanche avec
les élections on ne joue pas à la
revanche avec l'expression démocratique
mais que chaque voix compte vraiment
parce que si demain imaginons il n'y
avait pas cette majorité forte et
cohérente alors nous ne pourrions pas
voté le bouclier du pouvoir d'achat on
pourrait pas garder la remise sur sur
l'essence et le carburant on ne
permettrait pas aux pensions d'augmenter
avec l'inflation pourquoi les français
ne l'ont pas compris ça pourquoi ils se
sont abstenus et pourquoi ils n'ont pas
voté pour vous de façon beaucoup plus
important ce qui est certain c'est
qu'ils nous ont permis d'être second
tour dans une grande très large majorité
de circonscription et cae cae que j'ai
envie de parler aujourd'hui leur dire
mais leurs voix absolument elle compte
et je comprends que parfois et bien
notre projet n'a pas peut-être été le
plus audible peut-être pas suffisamment
clair parce que là il y avait une guerre
en ukraine parce qu'on sorte de l'aco
vide que la période elle est compliqué
c'est vrai mais plus que jamais il faut
pas laisser le choix aux extrêmes au
radicalité à l'outrance c'est les cinq
prochaines années qu'on joue est ce
qu'on prend à la légère la question de
la dette le programme de jean luc
mélenchon ses 320 milliards absolument
pas financé c'est quasiment un milliard
par c'est à nos enfants dont parle est
ce qu'on a envie de voir l'effondrement
de notre économie avec du yaka fokon et
finalement perdre nos emplois et bien
non et c'est pour ça que j'appelle
vraiment avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
sensibilité je comprends qu'ils aient
une part de parfois de déceptions
parfois pas d'engouement mais dimanche
prochain c'est un moment de vérité il
faut pas laisser la place au radicalisme
ans alors déjà j'entends parce que c'est
pas toujours le cas que vous
reconnaissez qu'il ya eu un message
brouillé c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire ça c'est intéressant j'aimerais
savoir puisque le président de la
république et à partir de demain en
roumanie en moldavie
peut-être en ukraine qui va mener la
bataille des législatives
en dehors de madame bornes edouard
philippe donne ce soir à nos confrères
du figaro une interview il estime qu'il
faut poursuivre l'élan réformateur et
que pour cela la majorité du de la
coalition présidentielle ne peut pas
être relative est-ce que puisque vous
êtes du modem est ce que françois bayrou
va lui aussi s'engager dans la bataille
pour prôner prêcher la bonne parole et
ramener ces abstentionnistes dont vous
dites qu'il considère que la politique
ne changent pas leur vie si bien sûr
puisque françois bayrou a été un des
grands défenseurs de la réforme
institutionnelle et la réforme nationale
c'est pas qu'une réforme de loi c'est
comment faire que chaque voix compte
avec la proportionnelle par exemple et
parce que fondamentalement la politique
c'est quoi c'est protéger la vie
quotidienne mais c'est aussi répondre
aux grands défis de notre temps mais
comment va le faire campagne et bien
principalement comme ce qu'il a fait
d'ailleurs dans le premier tour en étant
présent sur un certain nombre de
circonscriptions il a vraiment battu
campagne
il n'y a pas eu de débat national n'y a
pas eu de deux d'éléments de slogan
national de campagne nationale images
elisabeth bornes françois bayrou edouard
philippe côte à côte pour un sur une
estrade sur un mois dans une émission
très sincèrement ça c'est ça la campagne
très sincèrement moi ce que je vois
c'est des réponses et des campagnes sur
le terrain c'est 577 élections en
réalité une élection initiative et nous
avons besoin d'un élan national bien sûr
et ça c'est notre programme c'est notre
projet mais si présent de la république
cette semaine et à l'international
pourquoi il à l'internât salle parce
qu'il ya une guerre en europe et parce
que les propos de monsieur mélenchon est
la guerre albert l'a nullement chanot
signe mais pardon n'est pas hélas le
vote de dimanche c'est pour les cinq
prochaines années et quand on entend un
monsieur mélenchon dire il faut sortir
de l'otan il faut finalement détricoter
l'union européenne et faire une sorte de
fric si tu me dis alors même que les
verts finalement font comme s'il
n'entendait rien et que le parti
socialiste ne défend plus ces valeurs
essentielles de laïcité et tout le monde
tellement fait comme si c'était pas si
grave bien sûr que c'est absolument
essentiel c'est un projet de société est
aujourd'hui moi j'ai envie de dire à
ceux qui peut-être ne vais pas le
candidat de leur coeur celui qu'ils
avaient envie de de porter et bien de
leur dire dimanche prochain ce n'est
plus une question simplement et bien
d'élan c'est une question de ce
quasiment de survie de notre vie
démocratique pour les cinq prochaines
années il nous faut pas 50 bazar ou cinq
ans de repli ou cinq ans de franchement
de blocage nous avons besoin d'une
majorité cohérente forte et avec un peu
d'expérience ça fait pas de mal car elle
rit on n'a pas compris les consignes de
vote si qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
comment vous faites est ce que vous
mettez un signe d'égalité entre jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen est ce que
vous dites au cas par cas la phrase de
ce matin à pales c'était laborieux parce
qu'il ressort c'était quelques phrases
aujourd'hui c'était d'autres en bref on
y est arrivé c'est pas une voie pour le
rassemblement national mais ça veut dire
quoi et est ce que vous allez finalement
choisir des députés sur lesquels il
drague seront fréquentable d'autres pas
fréquentable d'autres très sincèrement
aimé cref moi mon engagement il a
toujours été en défense des valeurs de
la république il y a des essentiels d
essentiel c'est la laïcité le respect de
nos forces de l'ordre de nos
institutions on ne dit pas tout et son
contraire et surtout on ne vient pas à
battre s'épiler qui font qu'on est la
france l'ex le vote du second tour dans
les 58 circonscriptions il y à un front
national et un du ps c'est très clair
zéro voix pour le front national ça
c'est clair et net ce n'est pas un parti
pour lequel aucune de nos doigts aucune
de nos voix ne doit aller la new pis
pour moi eh bien c'est la même chose
l'agneau paix sans grande majorité une
chose il ya quelques exceptions c'est la
même chose que le rassemblement national
sûr il ya quelques exceptions mais très
minime que la ligne reste c'est la même
chose que le rassemblement national
c'est l'extrême pour moi c'est l'extrême
gauche la nuit passée l'alliance de
l'extrême gauche il y à quelques
exceptions pourquoi je précise parce que
il ya certains candidats qui viennent
effectivement du parti socialiste est
qui qui font comme si c'était pas si
grave est que illzach ce n'est qu'entre
mention huysman ils font quelle
compromission et cela eh bien je pense
toujours le quoi
il comprend très loin du lieu où les
discours mais parce que par exemple moi
j'ai été à l'assemblée nationale face
pour le coup à madame rabot et elle n'a
rien d'anti républicains mme adama drabo
évoqué la confiance à mélenchon 6 offre
et la grille sauf qu'elle fait campagne
avec monsieur manchois c'est pour ça que
nous avons nous avons fait campagne
contre elle nous avons fait campagne
contre elle valérie rabault c'est la
présidence du groupe socialiste sortant
à conviction gros pour l'abus puce en
grande majorité en grande majorité sauf
quelques exceptions effectivement mais
parce que vous savez cette alliance de
la new baisse elle n'a rien en commun et
donc avec beaucoup de responsabilités
bien on regarde le détail est
malheureusement malheureusement certains
ont cédé à la soumission de monsieur
mélenchon et malgré ça notre
responsabilité c'est de défendre les
républicains et les malgré sa route
david la ducasse n'a rien en commun dit
vous on peut être d'accord mais on a
quand même le sentiment que c'est
parfois la même chose chez vous sur
cette question de la consigne de vote
j'en veux pour preuve que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale actuelle a dit
exactement l'inversé de son public était
encore son prédécesseur il ya deux mois
jean michel blanquer c'est à dire que
lundi ni l'un ni l'autre ni rn line ups
lalanne ubs l'abomination de la
désolation et pap ndiaye dit le
contraire aux fauves haute et du ps
contre eux le rassemblement national
comment vous expliquez ça et comment
vous percevez la façon dont les lecteurs
dimanche prochain va mettre un bulletin
dans l'urne c'est quand même
incompréhensible vous savez pourquoi
c'est si incompréhensible parce que
parce que du ministre disait le bon
parce que leurs deux lits bull vient en
fait de la new baisse ne ressemble à
rien et que finalement ils se sont mis
d'accord derrière derrière un homme qui
souhaite qu'à qu'une seule énergie celle
de la vengeance celle de se venger
d'élections président de palau là vous
pourriez avoir une position une position
univoque et unique ne sait pas que les
très sincèrement quand on a siégé
pendant plusieurs années avec certains
députés socialistes qui ont défendu par
exemple je pense à la loi séparatisme
sur des essentiels qui ont été
absolument forte et qui malheureusement
se sont soumis à monsieur mélenchon
notre responsabilité c'est aussi de
connaître et bien et de reconnaître leur
ancrage leur défense de certaines au cas
par cas
elles sont minimes mais effectivement un
petit beau quand même sur les
républicains ils sont restés enfin on va
voir dans les projections il va
peut-être 50 60 on a entendu jean
françois copé et christian jacob dire
bah il y aura des choses sur lesquelles
peut-être qu'on peut voter est ce que
vous dites aux électeurs de droite on
pourra faire des choses ensemble bien
sûr parce que ce sont des républicains
évidemment et parce que on voit un
certain tous les électeurs des deux
allait passer quoi vous faites du cas
par cas pour nous paie c'est ce que vous
faites du cas par cas pour à l'air vous
savez quand on a un candidat ensemble
face à un candidat d'extrême gauche
portée par jean luc mélenchon évidemment
j'appelle les électeurs et bien de lui
dit de des républicains des sociaux
démocrates qui ne se sont pas mobilisés
au premier tour des libéraux des
européens de nous rejoindre sur ses
valeurs absolument essentiel il faut pas
se tromper c'est plus un projet
uniquement qui est porté c'est vraiment
finalement une vision absolument
diamétralement opposées c'est l'extrême
gauche avec la désobéissance avec des
propos absolument infecte sur les forces
de l'ordre sur l'école sur sur des
essentiels et finalement nous avec un
projet cohérent et peut-être que ce
n'était pas le leur au premier tour mais
plus que jamais nous avons besoin d'une
mobilisation vous appelez à une forme
d'alliance avec les républicains à
chaque fois bien sûr que les
républicains seront présents pour porter
ce projet ils sont les bienvenus et
j'appelle leurs électeurs bien sûr à se
mobiliser pour faire barrage à cette
extrême gauche merci beaucoup ça râle
aérien derniers mois avant qu eric
brunet à peut-être
succèdent vous parlez beaucoup du projet
notre projet notre projet le problème
moi je discutais beaucoup d'électeurs ma
chronique du premier tour quand je leur
dis c'est quoi le projet ils savent pas
moi je peux vous dire en quelques mois
quatre jours quelque narrer quelques
points essentiels parce que j'ai porté
sur ma circonscription
c'est que immédiatement là l'urgence
c'est quoi ces l'indexation des pensions
de retraite pour les personnes les plus
âgées parce qu'on a une inflation c'est
le dégel du point d'indicé pour
l'affronter tout ça on savait par
exemple
on doit pouvoir d'achat on sait on sait
pas eh bien ça n'aura été autant vous
tenez il ya quinze jours ça aurait été
bien d'annoncer ces faits là ça va être
exactement la mise en oeuvre de cette
urgence la de continuer le bouclier
tarifaire parce qu'aujourd'hui mois sur
le sur les marchés qu'est ce qu'ils me
disent des gens me disent ça devient
compliqué nos salaires ne suffisent plus
et bien de notre responsabilité c'est
d'avoir une majorité pour voter c'est
pas avoir eh bien ça va être évidemment
une retraite à 65 une retraite par
répartition défendu protéger mais
surtout permettre aussi une retraite à
1100 euros parce que ce que j'ai vu
c'est aussi des retraités merci